alors nucléaire stop ou encore on vous
pose la question ce soir sur notre
compte et d g d'ayrté france on attend
vos réactions et place maintenant à
notre face à face
avec nous pour en parler sur ce plateau
philippe muray re économie souverainiste
spécialiste également de l'écologie car
vous êtes l'auteur philippe muller de
comment réaliser la transition
écologique un défi passionnant aux
éditions jean cyrille godefroy merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés en duplex
bonsoir stéphane lhomme ancien porte
parole du réseau sortir du nucléaire
bonsoir stéphane lhomme merci d'être
avec nous une réaction à tout d'abord
aux témoignages qu'on vient d'entendre
le maire de fessenheim est évidemment
très énervé il vit remplacer le
nucléaire par des énergies renouvelables
tout ça c'est du discours c'est même de
l'escroquerie intellectuelle vous
partager ce constat philippe muray j'ai
trouvé son intervention très
intéressante et très juste et plein de
bon sens effectivement c'est de
l'escroquerie pourquoi la france a
aujourd'hui
l'électricité avec le moins d'émissions
de co2 en europe avec la suède
l'allemagne qui a fermé son nucléaire à
dix fois plus d'émissions de co2 et
justement parce qu'elle ferme son
nucléaire alors pour quelle raison si on
ferme le nucléaire comme on ferme une
france centrale comme fessenheim que va
falloir qu'ils faire on va mettre des
énergies renouvelables du solaire et des
rôles et de l'éolien qui vont produire
la moitié du temps quand il ya du soleil
ou du vent l'autre moitié du temps les
gens consomment de l'électricité il faut
donc le produire avec des centrales au
gaz pilotable qu'on met en route ou pire
des centrales au charbon donc on voit
automatiquement fermés du nucléaire
c'est avoir au moins pour moitié des
énergies fossiles consommer beaucoup
plus de co2 et et mettre beaucoup plus
de co2 d'ailleurs rte ledit réseau de
transport d'electricité de france le dit
il si on ferme le nucléaire il va
falloir mettre beaucoup d'énergie
renouvelable mais mettre beaucoup de
centrales au gaz pourquoi parce que
l'électricité pas stockables
l'électricité pas stockables je finis
rapidement en fait si vous voulez
l'académie des sciences explique que
pour stocker deux jours d'électricité il
faut sept ans de production mondiale de
lithium donc on peut pas stocker
l'énergie éolienne et la remettre dans
le réseau quand on veut donc c'est un
gâchis financier de 3 milliards d'euros
un outil 3 milliards d'euros qui a 20
ans à vivre et qu'on a gâché qu'on a
jeté trop tôt c'est un gâchis humain
avec 1000 personnes qu'ils ont jetés à
la porte émile peine 1000 emplois
indirects qui sont détruits enfin c'est
un gâchis de co2 c'est 3 millions de
tonnes de co2 émis en plus par la france
à cause de sa sphère des problèmes dans
l'ordre et dans la continuité de ce que
vous dites d'ailleurs justement le maire
de fessenheim qui dit aussi jamais le
renouvelable ne pourra remplacer des
centrales nucléaires ça ne peut venir
qu'en complément vous êtes un ancien
parole avant le 10 et du réseau sortir
du nucléaire cela doit vous hérisser le
poil tous ses discours stéphane lhomme
oui alors déjà je suis directeur de
l'observatoire du nucléaire et je
renvoie les spectateurs vers ce
d'excellents sites de notre association
est donc déjà rappelé qu'il ya 36000
communes en france et qui en a 19 qui
ont bénéficié d'un véritable jackpot
pendant 40 ans dont fessenheim et c'est
un descendant le maire bis avait coûté
nous on avait le jackpot et on on trouve
pas normal que ça s'arrête et les 36
1970 communes en france qui n'ont pas de
centrales nucléaires elles font comment
donc il faudrait arrêter de se diviser
et puis surtout pour revenir de manière
globale il faut rappeler que sur la
planète l'énergie c'est à 80% le trio
carbonées comme on dit c'est à dire
pétrole gaz charbon à 18% les énergies
renouvelables et deux seulement le
nucléaire donc le nucléaire c'est une
énergie il ya une part extrêmement
faibles n'y a qu'en france qu'on ne le
sait pas parce que ça fait 50 ans qu'on
nous libère c'est merveilleux
extraordinaire
mais en réalité sur la planète 2% de la
consommation mondiale d'énergie une part
très faible est en déclin dix minutes
pour le temple donc ceux qui racontent
qu'on va sauvez le climat avec le
nucléaire et d'écouter ses mensonges
puisque au contraire sur les 400
réacteurs en service sur terre
actuellement les annales l immense
majorité qui est en fin de vie et donc
ce qui se passe c'est que les réacteurs
sperme les uns que les autres aux états
unis il y avait 105 d'acteurs mon
service n'a plus 90 et la france a
commencé à fermer aussi non pas pour des
décisions idéologiques comme on essaie
de nous faire croire mais tout
simplement parce que ces réactions sont
délabrés sont en fin de vie et que edf
n'a plus les moyens de les entretenir
alors la question
c'est qu'est ce qu'on va faire quand
tous ces réacteurs vont s'arrêter c'est
à dire très vite au niveau énergétique
c'est dans dix quinze ans et demain
matin et effectivement on n'a pas de
solution mais c'est pas le nucléaire il
va nous sauver le nucléaire c'est une
énergie 20e siècle c'est fini il faut
plus compter sur le docteur alors ça a
suscité pas mal de débats sur 100 notre
compte télégramme verte et france
justement gilou lui pense avoir la
solution il dit le nucléaire est un bon
choix abondance d'énergie faible le coup
pas de rejets dans l'air et il poursuit
en mai poursuivre avec demandant aussi
d'investir justement et d'innover dans
le traitement du combustible usagé par
la fission et l'air de se connaître et
aussi dans les centrales elles mêmes
c'est un petit peu dans la continuité de
ce que vous nous dites stéphane lhomme
c'est que la voilà on arrive à la fin ça
veut dire philippe muray re qu'il faut
investir davantage désormais dans de
nouvelles centrales qui sont désormais
vieille obsolète ah oui oui ça c'est
certain mais on n'arrive pas à la fin
ils ont 35 ans il ya des centrales aux
états unis qui ont 62 ans en fait on
quand elles ont 40 ans les centrales en
france on les vérifie on les rénove on
met beaucoup d'argent par le grand
carénage c'est extrêmement rentable edf
a tout à fait les moyens de le faire edf
gagne 4 milliard d'euros ce trimestre se
mettre vous voyez donc edf a beaucoup
d'argent pour le faire ce n'est pas un
souci mais si on ferme le nucléaire tout
de suite il faut quand même voir en
france si on le ferme et tout de suite
on déjà on pourrait pas produire les
combats très durs renouvelables et des
centrales en gaz ça sera impossible mais
c'est où on augmenterait de 50 % les
émissions de co2 de la france on
mettrait 100 milliards d'euros à la
poubelle qui pourrait durer 25 ans et
c'est une filière de 250000 personnes
sans compter que c'est vraiment une
énergie de l'avenir la chine et les
etats-unis sont en train de faire
beaucoup de recherches et de lancer des
prototypes de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires encore plus sûre et avec de
l'énergie moins cher il y a aussi le
giec même le giec pour le climat dit
qu'en fait pour le nuc dans tous ces
scénarios ces quatre scénarios pour les
décideurs en fait il faut tripler la
part d'énergie nucléaire dans le monde
pour avoir moins d'émissions de co2 et
moi je réponds à monsieur stéphane
lhomme c'est à dire qu'en fait si la
france a par habitant des émissions de
co2 inférieures ou très terrien moyens
c'est le grand pays du monde qui a des
émissions de co2 les plus faibles c'est
parce que justement la moitié de notre
énergie utile l'électricité est
complètement pratiquement complètement
décarbonés en france merci le nucléaire
il faut investir dans toutes les
nouvelles générations n'en parlera
peut-être après stéphane lhomme
justement ça serait de l'argent gâché
pour vous d'investir dans les nouvelles
filières nucléaires d'ailleurs c'est ce
que veut faire aussi emmanuel macron
avec ses petits réacteurs notamment
c'est une bêtise pour vous
oui ce sont des filières
n'existe pas ils partent de zéro donc si
on veut sauver la planète
en oubliant qu'il ya des catastrophes
nucléaires déchets radioactifs mais si
on parle même peut simplement utiles à
construire des réacteurs on voit à
flamanville le réacteur le p r le fameux
le père devait rentrer en service en
2012 et là plus de dix ans de retard si
on construit de nouveaux réacteurs ils
seront effectives dans 20 dans le 30 ans
donc on voit bien que c'est une
impasse absolue nous ne jamais oublier
que le l'électricité ce n'est que 20 %
de l'énergie consommée dans un pays
comme en france donc le nucléaire ce
n'est qu'une partie de ces 20 %
c'est-à-dire que quand on dit que le
nucléaire va empêcher le réchauffement
climatique c'est une plaisanterie
l'énergie à nouveau ses 80% de l'énergie
montrant le gaz charbon 18 ans il est
renouvelable les renouvelables ces
immenses est il important sur la planète
que le nucléaire le nucléaire ce sont
des problèmes gigantesques de
catastrophes de déchets d'accès à l'ena
à la bombe atomique mais l'allemand pour
une contribution un film à la marche
économique de la planète est à nouveau
une contribution diminue le nucléaire
c'était 17% de l'électricité dans le
monde en 2001 ce n'est plus que 9% ça
diminue tout le temps et ça va continuer
parce que l'immense majorité des
réacteurs sont en fin de vie donc
l'humanité se massent à de très graves
difficultés c'est évident au niveau
énergétique au niveau climat mais ce
n'est certainement pas le nucléaire qui
va nous sauver est éloquent on le voit
avec les quatre
oui parce que je dirais que monsieur
stéphane lhomme et citoyens du monde qui
dirige la planète et que c'est lui et
qui prend les grandes masses pas ce qui
m'intéresse monsieur c'est pas glam
c'est ce qui se passe en france là où on
peut agir là on peut voter pour changer
les choses c'est déjà en regardant petit
en regardant autour de soi et en
agissant autour de soi qu'on altère pas
en disant à la chine ce qu'elle doit
faire
d'ailleurs je vous le signale l'écologie
mondialiste il ya tout les coop il faut
quand même en parler ça fait 26 coop qui
espaces en fait chaque fois ils nous
disent dans un an on va diminuer les
émissions de co2 ça va aller mieux vous
savez combien on a augmenté les
émissions de co2 avec cette vision de
mondialiste 50% de hausse des émissions
de co2 depuis qu'on dit qu'on va les
réduire donc il faut arrêter de regarder
mondialement faut regarder au niveau de
notre pays et faire au mieux possible il
ya autre chose qui est faux qui est dit
en tout cas de fa dassieu l'énergie en
fait l'électricité en france c'est la
moitié de l'énergie utile pourquoi si
vous prenez par exemple une unité
d'électricité et que vous la mettez dans
un moteur électrique il ya 90 %
drôlement vous prenez une unité de
pétrole et bien vous n'avez plus que 30
% de rendement donc il faut trois unités
de pétrole pour avoir le même rendement
pratiquement qu'une unité d'électricité
ou en fait ça représente bien la moitié
grosso modo de l'énergie utile consommée
en france donc ce qu'il faut
effectivement et c'est là on voit qu'on
marche sur la tête il faut pas penser à
réduire la production électrique
puisqu'on veut se passer de pétrole et
de gaz il faut augmenter la production
électrique en france il faut à peu près
là doublé pour se passer des énergies
fossiles pétrole et gaz et donc ça
d'électricité qui va servir soit
directement dans des moteurs électriques
soit à fabriquer de l'hydrogène pour
alimenter l'économie l'hydrogène des
voitures hydrogène d'être un hydrogène
qui existe déjà et qui sont de série
donc là on a vraiment un moyen d'avoir
de l'énergie sans co2 de l'énergie
produit en france avec des emplois
français au lieu de dépenser 60
milliards d'euros ailleurs et ça passe
par des énergies renouvelables qui
serviront pour l'hydrogène et de
l'énergie nucléaire qui sert pour
fabriquer de l'électricité pour la
consommation d'électricité une
électricité stable alors rien un autre
message en a plein celui de fred stop ou
encore les deux à la fois stop car il
faut développer le traitement des
déchets nucléaires où en est-on
interrogations encore pour notre
indépendance énergétique ça ce je sais
que c'est un sujet qui vous tient à
coeur philippe muray re
l'indépendance énergétique
elle passe par le nucléaire stéphane
lhomme
eh bien non c'est pour nous raconte
mais tout le monde voit bien qu'il ya
des augmentations du prix du gaz ou
d'électricité la france est touchée ne
n'oublions pas que à nouveau le
nucléaire il ne s'occupe que de
l'électricité et l'électricité ce n'est
que 20% du problème donc le lecteur le
nucléaire en france et 17 % de notre
énergie c'est 70 % de notre électricité
mais ce n'est que 17 % de notre énergie
donc le nucléaire alors qu'il est
développé au maximum en france ne nous a
jamais protégé ne nous protège pas au
contraire et nous met en danger et mais
on nous met en danger financièrement
aussi puisque edf maintenant est à bout
de souffle et ans areva a fait faillite
edf est quasiment en faillite donc il
faut inventer un autre modèle alors
c'est un peu naïf peut-être mais on sait
que la seule vraie solution ça serait
que d'un point nous les êtres humains
sur terre en deviennent sobre qu'on
consomme très peu d'énergie le moins
possible et qu'on soit raisonnable
malheureusement je crains que ça ne soit
pas le cas et à nouveau le nucléaire
c'est 2 % de l'énergie mondiale c'est
pas ça qui va nous sauver au compteur
puisque ça nous rajoute des catastrophes
et des déchets mais ça n'empêche
absolument pas tous les autres problèmes
il murray rapidement sur l'indépendance
énergétique parce qu'on va on va pour
aborder une autre idée celle du coup
mais non notamment en fait en france on
a conservé tout l'uranium 238 en fait
parce que c'est l'uranium 235 qui sert à
produire d'énergie tout l'uranium 238 on
en a pour milan si on les utilise dans
les nouvelles générations de réacteurs
d'ailleurs le projet astrid que monsieur
macouin arrêté on a mille ans de stock
on a aussi 85 ans de stock de thorium
qui ont sont dans des entrepôts qui ont
été exploitées dans des mines en fait
qui ont été trouvés dans des mines quand
on exploitait des métaux est en fait ce
thorium pas être utilisée aussi dans des
centrales nucléaires apport yom qui sont
encore beaucoup moins dangereuses que
les centrales nucléaires classiques ce
qu'en fait le thorium c'est comme faire
brûler du bois mouillé donc dès que vous
arrêtez de mettre du feu en dessous en
fait cela s'arrête complètement donc on
a toute cette énergie et cette
indépendance énergétique qui est à
portée de main maintenant il faut faire
des efforts planifié mettre de l'argent
sur le long terme et certainement pas
comme emmanuel macron dit je ferme
fessenheim est en fait mon projet c'est
le nucléaire avec 6 le père ça ça n'a
pas de sens c'est vrai qu'on parlait de
l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie
qu'on connaît tous comment dire aux
français a fini ce qu'elle fait de
l'homme on enlève les centrales c'est
d'ailleurs la question de boris
nous interpelle pardon encore pour le
nucléaire et par quoi le remplacer
qu'ils soient autant décarbonés et
productifs c'est vrai que c'est souvent
la question qui revient vous allez
mettre des champs d'éoliennes partout
stéphane lhomme qui produisent
finalement peu c'est la critique là qui
revient quand même souvent sur le tapis
alors à nouveau il faut bien le parc
nucléaire actuel on en bénéficie parce
que il a été massivement financés par
l'argent dans les années 70 et 80 mais
c'est quelque chose qui va s'arrêter et
qui ne pourra plus être reproduits
puisque les caisses des états et d'edf
sont complètement vide donc si vous
voulez on a mangé notre pain blanc on a
échappé de peu à des catastrophes
nucléaires comme bayonne 19 on a eu de
la chance mais ça ça s'arrête maintenant
construire de nouveaux records de pertes
c'est des sommes astronomiques pour des
réacteurs peu d'ailleurs ni edf ni areva
n'arrive à construire donc en fait la
question est effectivement réel qu'est
ce qu'on va faire à la fin d'une ère
mais on mettra pas caire parce que c'est
impossible à fabriquer de nouveaux
réacteurs edf n'y arrive pas impossible
et je suis lancé donc on est
effectivement dans une très grande on a
en effet face à une impasse on avance on
avance on avance on ne prévoit aucune
alternative et ne tellement pas oublier
que c'est sonnailles ne ferme et 1 6 2
des dizaines d'autres réacteurs relaxe
permis en france ce ne sont pas des
questions idéologiques comme si tu peux
faire par edf et les gens qui
soutiennent le nucléaire c'est tout
simplement que ces réacteurs
edf n'a pas les moyens de nouveau et que
tout simplement ce que l'on bat
s'arrêter et quand je dis va s'arrêter
c'est très bientôt s'il en quelques
années et on a aucune alternative est
donc ce qui va rester
c'est à dire importer massivement de
l'électricité faut savoir que on
critique beaucoup les allemands avec
leurs centrales électriques au charbon
mais ce sont eux qui chauffe la france
tous les bébés parce que avec tous les
choses à gérer mon ami en france eh bien
on est obligé d'importer les ibères
parce que notre modèle centrales
nucléaires le chauffage électrique est
absurde et ne fonctionne
je voyais à faire les grands gens qui
france plus anti france que monsieur
stéphane lhomme c'est pas possible quand
je veux dire en plus des torrents de
mensonges dont la france ne se chauffent
pas avec l'électricité allemande de
temps en temps il ya des accords ou la
france exporte beaucoup vers l'allemagne
de temps en temps un stylo mais elle
n'en a absolument pas besoin est là des
centrales hydrauliques ou elle qu'elle
peut relâcher pour produire de
l'électricité à la demande donc faut
arrêter les mensonges sur la sécurité
quand même philippe frère parce que
c'est vrai que
je fais là s'est contenu 2d d'accord
ça ne va pas trop les il n'y a pas eu
d'accident clairement parce que
l'entreprise attention et public c'est
ça qui est fondamental edf est une
entreprise publique contrairement à
l'entreprise aux entreprises japonaises
de production d'électricité est
américaine et donc il y à une exigence
de rentabilité mais qui vient après la
sécurité est justement la grosse erreur
est de mettre ds en bourse il faut
absolument pas que des faubourgs soit en
bourse guidés par le prix de ses actions
la rentabilité immédiate il faut
absolument que des f soit 100% public
pour se préoccuper uniquement à long
terme de la sécurité et de
l'approvisionnement énergétique alors il
est impossible de financer des centrales
nucléaires mais comment on peut entendre
ça le général de gaulle s'il avait
entendu ça et tout laisser et success
dargaud liste ils ont mis 200 milliards
d'euros sur la table pour fabriquer les
centrales nucléaires que nous avons ils
ont fait en quinze ans la transition
énergétique c'est à dire qu'ils ont
réussi à ce que la france passent
massivement d'énergies fossiles à
l'énergie nucléaire tout cela parce
qu'ils avaient des ambitions se sont pas
des gens qui comme monsieur stéphane
lhomme sont les bras ballants on peut
rien faire impossible de les fabriquer
on peut les fabriquer ses centrales
alors le p r c'est vrai est un réacteur
qui est mal née parce qu'il est né sous
la pression politique avec en fait de
plus en de plus en plus d'injonction au
cours du temps pour toujours plus de
sécurité et donc les dessins ou été sans
arrêt modifié d'autant les allemands
sont rentrés dans le programme puis en
sont sortis quelques années plus tard
ont chamboulé le programme donc voilà
pourquoi ce réacteur est pas fantastique
pour la sécurité optimale alors il y a
effectivement le père et d'une sécurité
encore plus grande que les centrales
d'avant mais il ya ces petits réacteurs
nucléaires et notamment toute la filière
que recherche la chine en ce moment
c'est à dire affiche avec des selles
liquides des selles liquides dont le
liquide de refroidissement
c'est au lieu de l'eau ce qui permet de
ne pas avoir de pression dans les
centrales donc il ya beaucoup moins de
risques et s'il y avait une catastrophe
naturelle comme fukushima était
impossible vous déversez en fait tout le
liquide avec le carburant vous le mettez
par une femme dans un circuit extérieur
il se refroidit automatiquement donc
vous n'avez plus de risque d'accident
importants comme ça s'est passé à
fukushima maintenant il faut avoir envie
de le faire il faut avoir envie
d'investir de planifier sur le long
terme et d'avoir une vision politique
parce que l'énergie c'est pas une vision
à deux ans c'est une vision à 20 ans
qu'il faut prendre pour que tout le
monde puisse travailler bien dans la
bonne direction stéphane lhomme très
rapidement le mot de la fin de ce qu'on
arrive vraiment tout au bout quand vous
voyez tous ces candidats y compris jean
luc mélenchon qui ont un peu rebrousser
chemin qui n'ose pas vraiment qu'ils
n'osent plus vraiment parler de la
sortie du nucléaire fin mélenchon en
parle mais à un horizon plus lointain
que ce qu'ils avaient imaginé au début
on vous dit quoi qu'il ya quand même un
problème d' alternative très rapidement
s'il vous plaît parce qu'on on arrive
vraiment la fin
oui il ya un problème d'alternative mais
le nucléaire ne succèdera pas au
nucléaire comme l'équipe cette industrie
et c'est comme un poulet sans tête et
continue à courir un jour on nous dit
faut faire les gros réacteur après 90
des petits après rome et la fusion
nucléaire et après les surgénérateurs
c'est une industrie qui ne sait plus où
elle va elle est moribonde je rappelle
le nucléaire c'est 17% de l'électricité
mondiale en 2001 ce n'est plus que 9% ça
fait adopter 1% de la consommation
mondiale d'énergie donc en fait c'est
une énergie résiduelles qui va
disparaître heureusement mais les
problèmes de la planète et on nous tous
des humains sur terre et problèmes
d'énergie et de climat reste entier vont
pas être réglé en deux doigts mais en
tout cas la disparition de l'unitaire
permettra de se poser les vraies
questions et d'été de castille et notre
argent dans le temps ne
s'éclaire à la bougie en attendant je
vous taquine merci en tout cas dans
merci beaucoup stéphane lhomme philippe
muller d'avoir été avec nous